a Grammy nominated gospel singer was
nearly booted off a Delta flight when
she refused to stop performing her new
single which she insisted was just her
doing what the Lord is telling me to do
was like you know I haven't done this in
a while I've gotten to the next status
so are able to be quiet but they're
enjoying it so while we're sitting here
can I please I'm not enjoying it so I'm
asking you can you be
quiet that's say yes or no answer please
am I going to go to jail if I don't can
you please answer my question are you
willing and able to be quiet right now
I'm doing what the Lord what is telling
me to do I'm asking you a question yes
or no I'm your flight leader I need you
to follow my instruction okay my
instruction for you to answer my
question are you able to be quiet what
do you guys think she's asked to sit
down on the plane and she says no it's
okay I'm I'm charting on the Billboards
so she thinks that that's some sort of
maybe she could just walk into the
cockpit ma'am you can't be in here it's
okay I'm charting on the Billboards
everything's fine